trumpest threats
to the fbi including individual agents
involved in the search warrant served at
donald trump's mar-a-lago
and more generally to the justice
department are exploding
we know
that trumpists are willing to do
violence in great numbers we saw it on
january 6th
and
for being about backing the blue
and the thin blue line
and support the police and defend the
police and all of this different stuff
they abandoned that immediately
when it is not convenient we saw it on
january 6th on january 6th all of a
sudden
the police officers
at the capitol were trying to stop
trumpists from getting inside
they were engaging trumpist and trying
to physically prevent them from uh
staying inside
and all of a sudden police weren't the
good guys they were the bad guys they
don't actually care about police they're
saying that they don't actually care
about the military oh would always
defend the military etc
and yet we saw with the iraq war of
george w bush very willing to just send
our members of the military into harm's
way
for no actual good empirically backed
reason so we're seeing the exact same
thing fbi and dhs warn of increased
threats to law enforcement and
government officials after the
mar-a-lago search
the threats which are occurring
primarily online and across multiple
platforms including social media web
forums video sharing and image boards
were identified by the fbi and
department of homeland security in the
days following the fbi's authorized
seizure of 11 sets of classified
documents from the former president's
home including four sets classified tax
top secret according to the search
warrant
according to the bulletin the fbi and
dhs have observed an increase in violent
threats posted on social media against
federal officials and facilities
including a threat to place a so-called
dirty bomb in front of the fbi
headquarters and issuing general calls
for civil war and armed rebellion
that includes threats that are specific
in identifying proposed targets tactics
or weaponry
hmm
we also have this incident where three
days after the search ricky schiffer jr
wearing a technical vest and armed with
an ar style rifle and nail gun attempted
to forcibly enter the fbi's cincinnati
office and described the standoff it
described the standoff with fbi and law
enforcement officers that ultimately
resulted in schiffer's death
this is obviously expected
i said this on our first stream in in
the when we were streaming the day that
it was learned that this search warrant
was um uh acted on
i said
they are going to go after the fbi and
the doj these people are violent these
people claim to back the blue but that's
only when it's convenient that's when
it's george floyd
that's when it's antifa or black lives
matter but when it's their own they no
longer back the blue and some of you
said david that's hyperbole that's not
going to happen well it is happening
we've already had an armed guy show up
at the cnn field of cnn fbi
they may well show up at cnn as well the
fbi field office in cincinnati
we are seeing uh the doxing of the
individual fbi agents who participated
in serving the search warrant and they
are it's cause and effect that's all it
is it's a direct result
of the attacks on the verbal attacks on
the fbi law enforcement and the doj
trump did it marjorie taylor green did
it
it's dozens and dozens of republicans
saying defund the fbi
this is a gestapo the they are actually
the criminals and this is the exact
result and it's actually so bad i mean
we know the script we saw what happened
on january 6th it's so bad
that even a fox host is saying trump
should probably make it clear you
shouldn't go after the fbi agents